[موسيقى]
خوض الحروب على الورق اولا سيمنحك فرصه
اكبر في الانتصار داخل الميدان
فالقائد الناجح عليه ان يعرف جيدا من اين
يبدا وبمن سيبدا والى اين سيصل والاهم كيف
سيحصل على الدعم اللازم لتحقيق اهدافه
اهلا بكم في عسكرتك
[تصفيق]
بعد ان نجحت في اختباراتها في مايو الماضي
شركه نورثرو برومان تعلن عن اطلاق
ايقاذفاتها الاستراتيجيه الجديده بي 20 في
شهر ديسمبر المقبل القذفه التي تعد الاخطر
في القرن الحادي والعشرين حسب خبراء
عسكريين تحتوي على احدث انظمه الطيران
والاتصال والحرب الالكترونيه كما يمكنها
حمل قنابل ثقيله وتنفيذ عمليات قصف
استراتيجيه باسلحه تقليديه ونويه وايضا
صواريخ فرض صوتيه من المقرر ان تحصل
القوات الجويه الامريكيه على 100 قاذفه من
طراز ب 20 1 ويتوقع ايضا ان يتم بناء 100
قاذفه اخرى من نفس النوع في مرحله لاحقه
لتحل مكان جميع القاذفاتيه التي يمتلكها
سلاح الجو الامريكي
[موسيقى]
الجيش الفرنسي يستقبل 122 دبابه قتال
رئيسيه محدثه من طراز الكليرك اكس ال ار
بحلول عام 2025 هذه التحديثات على هذه
الدبابه هي جزء من برنامج يهدف لتطوير
جميع مركبات القتال في الخطوط الاماميه
للجيش الفرنسيه لتتمكن من العمل مع مختلف
المنصات وربطها بنظام موحد للاتصالات
وايضا برامج اداره المعارك وزياده التنسيق
الميداني بين الكتائب وتمكينها من الوصول
الى الاهداف التكتيكيه المحدده اثناء
التدخل العسكري
[موسيقى]
في اللي انت تتعاقد مع شركه البرت
الاسرائيليه للحصول على انظمه اتصال
لاسلكيه مؤمنه ومتطوره توفر قياده تكتيكيه
متوافقه مع الاجهزه اللاسلكيه التناظريه
التي يستخدمها الجيش الفنلندي في الوقت
الحالي العقد ان تبلغ قيمته 25 مليون
دولار ومن المنتظر ان يتم تنفيذه خلال
العامين المقبلين هذه المنظمات التي حصلت
عليها فنلندا تعمل بالفعل في عدد من الدول
الاوروبيه وايضا دول حلفته
انخفاض دوري الطائرات الحربيه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه بعد ان ظهرت بشكل كبير في
الايام الاولى للعمليه العسكريه الروسيه
وكذلك على الجانب الاخر تصعد دور الطائرات
المسيره الهجوميه والانتريه وايضا
الصواريخ بعيده المدى كل هذه الامور اثاره
العديد من الاسئله حول دور الطائرات
الحربيه التقليديه في حروب اليوم وايضا في
حروب المستقبل وهل تراجع دور الطائرات
الحربيه مقارنه بالطائرات
هذا ما سنطرحه على الفريق المتقاعد ديفيد
تولع عميد معهد ماتشات الطيران والباحث في
استراتيجيات الحرب الجويه اولا جنرال
ديفيد اهلا بك معنا في عسكريا هل تراجع
دوري طائرات الحربيه التقليديه امام
الطائرات المسيره ولماذا لم نجد دوري كبير
للقوات الجويه سواء من الجانب الروسي او
الجانب الاوكراني بعد الايام الاولى من
الحرب
[موسيقى]
على استضافه في هذا البرنامج الخلاصه
الاولى التي ينبغي استخلاصها من الحرب بين
روسيا واوكرانيا اليوم هي ان التفوق الجوي
يلعب دورا اساسيا في تحقيق النجاح لانه
يسمح بحريه الحركه لتفادي الهجوم علاوه
على القدره على شانه ولم يتمكن حتى الان
اي من طرفي الحرب من تحقيقه هذا التفوق
وهذا الوضع اطال امد الحرب وحولها الى حرب
استنزاف وهو ما نتج عنه ارتفاعه اعداد
الضحايا وزياده حجم الدمار بشكل اكبر من
ما كان سيحدث في حال اظهر اي من طرفيها
تفوقا في الجو وكما ذكرت فهناك طائرات
مسيره واستخدامها لتحقيق التفوق الجوي لكن
ليس لان الطائرات المقاتله التقليديه اقل
قيمه وانما نقص الكفاءه وسوء القياده
والتدريب والتجهيز الذي يتسم به سلاح الجو
الروسيه وفي الوقت ذاته فان الاوكرانيين ل
سلاح جو صغير مقارنه بروسيا بالتالي فانه
في هذه المواجهه عجز فيها الجانبان عن
تحقيق التفوق في الجو واعتقد ان جوهر
سؤالك عن قدره الطائرات المسيره على تعويض
الطائرات الحربيه التقليديه
وجواب عن سؤالك هو كلا لان المسيرات ما هي
الا اضافه للادوات التي يتم استخدامها من
اجل تحقيق اهداف المهمه المتمثله في
السيطره على الاجواء وتمكين القوات البريه
نتيجه لذلك من التحرك بحريه اكبر بغرض شن
الهجوم ما تستطيع ملاحظته هو ان
الاوكرانيين اظهروا مقدره كبيره على
استخدام سلاح الجو المتوفر لديهم الى جانب
انظمه الدفاع الجوي من اجل منع روسيا من
النفاذ الى مسافات بعيده في عمق الاراضي
الاخرانيه وهو ما جعل روسيا تعول اكثر على
الصواريخ والطائرات المسيره التي حصلت
عليها من ايران للتعوي عن عدم قدرتها على
القيام بنشاط عسكري في الاجواء الاوكرانيه
الجنرال ديفيد الصواريخ بعيده المدى ظهر
لها حضور كبير كذلك في الحرب لكن هل تعتقد
اللجوء الى مثل هذه الاسلحه سيدفع بعض
الجيوش لاعاده ترتيب هياكلها الداخليه ام
لا
مره اخرى وبالنسبه للصواريخ بعيده المدى
فان لها دورا باستطاعتها القيام به في اي
نساء وهي احدى الادوات التي يستخدمها سلاح
الجو لبلوغ الاهداف الخاصه بمهمه ما لكنها
ليست متوفره بالاعداد الكافيه لاستبدالها
بالطائرات الحربيه التي بوسعها مهاجمه
الاهداف بشكل متكرر والعوده الى قواعدها
للتسلح وتوجيه ضربات من جديد ولو نظرت الى
الاهداف التي تتعرض للتهديد في اي صراع
عصري ستجد انها اكثر مما تستطيع اي دوله
ان تتعامل معه با الصواريخ فقط
جنرال ديفيد الان الكثير من الدول تعمل
على تطوير طائرات من الجيل السادس برايك
ما هي الطائره التي ستكون طائره نموذجيه
بالشكل الاكبر
ما نشاهده في هذه الحرب التي تدور روحها
بين روسيا واوكرانيا هو دليل اضافي يدفع
باتجاه السعي للحصول على طائرات من الجيل
الجديد ويبدو ان روسيا عمدت الى استخدام
الطائرات المقاتله من الجيل الرابع التي
تحلق على ارتفاع المنخفض لتجنب الصواريخ
الاوكرانيه من طراز 300 وهو ما يجعلها
عرضه للاصابه بصوارخ فعاله ضد اهداف على
ارتفاعات المنخفضه مثل صواريخ ستينجر اما
بالنسبه للطائرات من الجيل الرابع فهي
تمثل خطرا اكبر من حيث رصد هذه الطائرات
واعتراضها بصواريخ ارض جو تعود لحكمه
الحرب البارده لذلك فان القاذفات تصاعب
مهمه رصدها وتحلق لفترات اطول وسترى
بالتاكيد المزيد من الاستثمارات تضخم
الاجيال المقبله من الطائرات الحربيه سواء
كانت من الجيل الخامس او السادس
الطيران والباحث في استراتيجيات الحرب
الجويه شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه التوضيحات
احدث القطع التي ستنضم قريبا للاسطول
البحري السعودي سفن القتال الساحلي التي
تنتجها شركه توكيد مارتن الامريكيه والتي
بدات بالفعل في تدشين السفينه الثانيه من
اصل اربع سفن تعاقدت عليها السعوديه في
عام 2017
سفن القتال الساحلي السي اس هي سفن حربيه
صغيره بحجم فرقاطه معده لتوفير مهام حمايه
السواحل والجزر وايضا تامين الاسناد البري
لعمليات القوات الخاصه ومكافحه الغواصات
في المياه
طرزان
والثاني هو ال اس اس ان
الطرزان مسلحان بمدفع عيار 57 ملليم
وصواريخ للدفاع الجوي القريب من طراز رم16
ومجهزان بمهبط وحظيره لطائرات هيليكوبتر
من طراز سيهوبك
المتطلبات الخاصه البحريه السعوديه دفعت
الشركه لتطوير راس خاص بها تحتسمه ان ان
وهي عباره عن سفينه ال سي اس فريدم مضاف
اليها بعض التعديلات كما ستكون مسلحه
بالصواريخ هاربون المضاده للسفن وايضا
بالصواريخ كام المضاده لطائرات وكذلك
بمدفعين رشاشين عيار 20 م وبمن السطين
لاطلاق توربيدات مضاده للغواصه
تصل سرعه السفينه الى 30 عقده في الساعه
كما انها تتمتع بخاصيه الشبح ما سيصاعد
عمليه رصدها على شاشات الرادار اضافه الى
كونها مجهزه بمجموعه من المسيارات الجويه
والبحريه لمهام الاستطلاع والانذار المبكر
[موسيقى]
بعد الفصل الفرنسيه شركه جديده تنضم
للاعبين الكبار في عالم الصناعات الدفاعيه
الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في شهر اكتوبر الماضي
اعلن عن ولاده شركه اكسال الفرنسيه هذه
الشركه جاءت نتيجه اندماج بين الشركتين
مختصتين في تصنيع الروبوتات والانظمه
المسيره
[موسيقى]
شركه اي سي اي وكذلك شركه اي اكس بلو
اعلنت عن توحيد قدرات الشركتين في مؤسسه
هذه المؤسسه تضم اليوم 1500 عاما ومهندس
وتقني كما يتوقع ايضا الا تقل ارباحها
الثانويه عن 150 مليون دولار فما اهداف
هذا الاندماج وكذلك كيف سينعكس على خطط
التصنيع داخل الشركه هذا ما سنتعرف عليه
مع رئيس التنفيذي لشركه اكسيل الحاليه
السيد يعني نابوليتانو اولا مستر فبيان
اهلا بك معنا في عسكريا ما هي اهداف هذا
الاندماج وكذلك ما هي تاثيراته على خطط
التصنيع على يديكم في المستقبل
ارجوكم
اندماج بين شركتين معرفتين في مجال
الروبوتكس هما اي اكس بلو والثانيه هي
ايكا وكلتهما من الشركات رائدات في مجال
الروبوتكس وخاصه في المجال البحري على مدى
20 عاما ونحن نلاحظ ان هذا المجال يتقدم
بسرعه كبيره لذلك قررنا ان نمضي يقود من
ونؤسس شركه جديده اسمها اكسيل لتوفر
الابتكارات الحديثه لعملائنا وتزودهم
بقدرات اضافيه لحل المشكلات ونرى انه عبر
اكسيل سنتمكن من تعزيز القدرات والامكانات
التي تتمتع بها الشركه همم المسافه بين
بعض منتجاتكم لديها استخدامات مزدوجه هل
على الجانب الاخر تعتقدون ان لديكم فرصه
في قطاع المسيارات البحريه الصغيره
اوكي السوق
تعمل في القطاعين المدني والدفاع ونرى
التطور السريعه يحدث على المستويين
العسكري والمدني في مجال تطوير الانظمه
المسيره لكننا نود ان يعمل العملاء على
رفع وتيره برامجهم التي يمكن ان تعمل دون
ضروره وجود نظام جي بي اس للاستدلال على
مواقع هذه المسايرات ونحن نعتبر هذه فرصه
كبيره لنا لتنمو واعمالنا في المجال
الدفاعيه والاستراتيجيه التي نعتمدها من
اجل ذلك هي اقامه علاقات شراكه لتعاوني مع
العملاء اضافه الى السعيين لتعاون مع
الشركات رائده في المجال او الذهاب مباشره
للتعاون مع الجيوش والقوات العسكريه في
الدول في ما يتعلق بالذكاء الاصطناعي
الكثير من الشركات التي تصنع او تعمل الان
على تصنيع منظومات مسيره او روبوتات يلجا
الى الذكاء الاصطناعي اين انتم من هذه
الاستخدامات والى اين وصلتم في هذه النقطه
تحديدا
من تطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي ونتمتع
بكوننا واحده من الشركات القليله في
العالم التي تتمتع بهذه القدرات خاصه
المنظومات البحريه فهناك شركات اخرى توفر
تطبيقات لمجالات مختلفه الا ان المختصين
بالمنظمات البحريه قله قليله نحن نستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي لهدفين رئيسيين اولهما
ضمان سلامه العمليات مثل الملاحه بسلامه
وتجنب الاصطدامات والالتزام بقواعد
الملاحه هذا احد جوانب دمج الذكاء
الاصطناعي اما المجال الاخر فهو تعزيز
قدرات المهام فالمسيرات التي نملكها قادره
على تغيير مهمتها تلقائيا فور اشعاري
وجودي جسم غريب في قاع البحر على سبيل
المثال عندها تقوم المسيره بتغيير مهمتها
لدينا هذه الامكانات هو القدرات التي نرى
انها مهمه جدا للمستقبل لذلك نواصل
استثمار في هذا المجال مصطفى بيان فيما
يتعلق يعني بعد ما اتممتم هذه العمليه من
الاندماج هل لديكم خطه للتوسع في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط خاصه بانه هذه المنطقه تحتضن
الكثير من الشركات الكبرى العامله في هذا
المجال الان
فيديو
ولديناه هنا الكثير من العملاء وعملائنا
دائما يطالبون والدينا برامج جوري الاقمار
الصناعيه كما نتعاون كثيرا مع القوات
البريه في السعوديه ومصر والبحرين وغيرها
من الدول كما نعمل على برامج تطبيقات
المحليه والمجال الذي انه يعد الانشطه فيه
هو المجال البحري حيث نتعاون مع جميع
القوات البحريه في المنطقه حيث كنا مؤخرا
نقدم خدماتنا للبحريه السعوديه فنحن
موجودون فعليا في المنطقه ولدين الكثير من
الشركات كما ننوي توسعه هذه الشركات فيما
يتعلق بنقله التكنولوجيا نحن نعتبر هذه
المساله بالطبع مساله حساسه لاننا شركه
تكنولوجيه والتكنولوجيا قيمتها عاليه جدا
لذلك نقوم باختيار شركائنا بحذر لكننا
قادرون على الانجاز ولدينا مثال جيد حليا
وهو شراكه مع البحريه البلجيكيه اذ لدينا
برامج معهم ومعه هولندا كذلك في اطار
التعاون التكنولوجي ونمل ان نحضر في
المستقبل بمثل هذه الفرصه للتعاونيه في
الشرق الاوسط
مصر فابيان نابوليتان ورئيس التنفيذي
لشركه اكس ال الفرنسيه شكرا جزيلا على كل
هذه التوضيحات
[تصفيق]
احدى اهم القاذفات خلال الحرب العالميه
الثانيه كما لعب دورا المحوريه في قصف
المدن الالمانيه
قذفت القنابل الاستراتيجيه ب 17 هذه
القذفه التي عرفت باسم القلعه الطائره
صممتها شركه بوينج الامريكيه لتنفيذ
عمليات بعيده المدى
دخلت هذه القذفه في الخدمه بالجيش
الامريكي في عام
وبقيت في الخدمه لدى دول العده حتى اواخر
الستينيات القرن الماضي بلغت حموله هذه
القاذفه
4300 كيلو جرام من القنابل شنطه اولى
غارتها على المانيا في عام
1941 ضمن سربه لسلاح الجو الملكيه
الغارات الاولى كشفت ضعف تسليح هذه القذفه
فتم تزويدها بمدافع رشاشه في مقدمه ومؤخره
الطائره وكذلك في جوانبها وبطنها وسطهاها
ولهذا وصفت بالقلعه الطائره
اكتسبت هذه القاذفه شهرتها بشكل خاص خلال
اخر سنتين من الحرب العالميه الثانيه حيث
ان 42% من القنابل التي القيت على المانيا
كانت من هذه القاذفات اضافه الى انها
استخدمت ايضا في مهام النقل والبحث
والانقاذ ومطارده الغواصه تم انتاج اكثر
من اثني عشر الف و700 قاذفه ب17 هذا الامر
جعل واحدا من اكثر القاذفات تصنيعا في
التاريخ كما خدمت لدى القوات الجويه في
اكثر من 20 دوله حول العالم ابرزها امريكا
وبريطانيا وفرنسا واسرائيل
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
يوما تلو الاخر تتصاعد المخاوف الدوليه من
تازم الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا وتحولها
من عمليه عسكريه محدوده الاهداف الى حرب
شامله فما هو مفهوم الحرب الشامله وفيما
تختلف في تطبيقها واستراتيجياتها
تعد من اقصى انواع الحروب واشدها وطاه على
الاطراف المتحاربه
الحرب الشامله مصطلح عسكري يقصد به تحقيق
النصر التام على الخصم دون تمييز بين هدف
عسكريا او مدني
هذا المصطلح بدا يستخدم من قبل المنظرين
العسكريين اواخر القرن التاسع عشر ومطلع
القرن العشرين ويتم عبر وضع استراتيجيه
تبنى على ان العدو ويشكل خطرا وجودا
يستدعي تعبئه العامه ومواجهه بكل انواع
الاسلحه وصولا الى الاستسلام التام للخصم
او ابادته
ويمكن ان تتطور الى حرب اباده تامه بين
شعبين يجب ان تنتهي بنصرا تام لاحدهما على
الاخر كما ان الحروب الاهليه تاخذ عاده
صفه الحرب الشامله كونها تبنى على اسس
عقائديه وفيها يحاول كل طرف الغاء الاخر
[موسيقى]
وتصنف الحرب العالميه الثانيه على انها
حرب شامله اذ اصر كل طرف فيها على
الاستسلام التام للطرف الاخر
اضافه الى استهداف المدنيين بشكل كبير مما
ادى الى سقوط ملايين القتلى وهذا ما دعى
المجتمع الدولي الى تعديل اتفاقيه الجناب
حول قوانين الحرب من اجل الحد من ظاهره
الحرب الشامله
واليوم يخشى خبراء ان تتحول الحرب في
اوكرانيا الى حرب شامله بين الروس
والاوكرانيين خاصه مع تهديد الرئيس الروسي
الذيمر بوتن باللجوء الى السلاح النووي
وحجم الدمار الذي يخلفه الروس في المدن
الاوكرانيه نتيجه اتباع استراتيجيه الارض
المحروقه
[موسيقى]
الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد
من الصفقات في امان الله
[موسيقى]